[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: FEELS GOOD, DON'T
EVER STOP, DON'T EVER LEAVE ME.
HAPPY WEDNESDAY.
DO NOT ADJUST THE TV I SIMPLY
GOT BETTER LOOKING SINCE YOU SAW
ME ON THE FIVE A FEW HOURS AGO,
IF IT KEEPS HAPPENING I'M GOOD
AT CHANGE THIS SHOW TO THE TEN.
I DON'T NEED THOSE PEOPLE.
TONIGHT I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
SOMETHING MIGHT NOT BE ON YOUR
RADAR BUT WILL BE SOON,
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION -- THAT'S
RIGHT AND COLLEGE ADMISSIONS
WHICH HAS ADVANCED MORE
UNQUALIFIED PEOPLE IN THE LAST
NAME BIDEN.
ON MONDAY THE SUPREME COURT
HEARD OF TWO CASES TO CHALLENGE
THE POLICIES AT UNC AND HARVARD
ARE AS I CALLED THEM MY SAFETY
SCHOOLS.
THE UNC CASE ARGUES USING RACE
IN ADMISSIONS VIOLATES CIVIL
RIGHTS LAW AND THE CONSTITUTION
OR WHAT THE DEMS REFER TO AS
THAT PAIN IN THE ASS SCRAP OF
PAPER, HARVARD IS ACCUSED OF
TERMINATING AGAINST ASIAN
STUDENTS, THE SCHOOL THAT
PRODUCED JOY REID, LIZ WARREN,
CHUCK SCHUMER, BARACK OBAMA, ALL
OF WHOM LOVE TO CALL OTHER
PEOPLE RACISTS.
THEY ARE MORE OBSESSED WITH
COLOR THAN A BOMB TECH CUTTING
RED AND BLUE WIRES.
I'M SO GLAD YOU GOT THAT.
I WAS GOING TO CUT IT OUT.
WHILE THE LEFT LOVES TO DEFEND
ALL MINORITIES FROM PERCEIVED
RACISM WITH ASIANS, THEY DON'T
GIVE A [BLEEP].
ICE PELLETS PHUK.
THE ASIAN WAY, THANK YOU.
I'M CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE,
THAT'S BECAUSE ASIANS FILL
SPACES IN GREAT COLLEGES IN
NUMBERS THAT ARE HIGHER THAN
THEIR PERCENTAGE OF THE GENERAL
POPULATION.
SO IT'S A GREAT MESSAGE FOR
TODAY'S YOUTH.
WORK HARD AND SACRIFICE AND SOME
DATE YOU TOO CAN GET MOVED TO
THE BACK OF THE LINE.
THAT'S HOW PUNITIVE IDEOLOGIES
WORK, THOSE WHO RISE GET POUNDED
DOWN IN THE NAME OF EQUITY, IT'S
NOT ABOUT EQUALITY OF
OPPORTUNITY ANYMORE BUT MAKING
EVERYBODY SUCK AT THE SAME
LEVEL.
IF YOU WANT THAT KIND OF
MEDIOCRITY, SKIP COLLEGE
ENJOYING THE VIEW.
THE ORAL ARGUMENTS BETWEEN
LAWYERS FOR BOTH SIDES TOOK
ALMOST SIX HOURS, IF ANYTHING
DONE ORALLY TAKES THAT LONG,
THEY MUST BE DOING IT WRONG.
WHAT WAS THAT?
WHAT'S WRONG WITH MAY COME
DISGUSTING.
SIX HOURS, WE PAUSE NOW TO WATCH
ALL OF IT.
>> YOU MISSED ME.
>> THAT WILL TEACH YOU.
>> GUESS WE LOADED THE WRONG
TAPE.
AT LEAST THEY DIDN'T LOAD THAT
OTHER TAPE LABELED ORAL.
ANYWAY, I'LL JUST FIRE THAT
PERSON LATER, I PAY IT FORWARD
BY DOING IT IN FRONT OF THEIR
CHILDREN.
[LAUGHTER]
EXPERTS THINK THE COURT WILL END
UP BANNING THE PRACTICE, LIBERAL
JUDGES ARE AGAINST THAT SAYING
YOU CAN'T HAVE DIVERSITY WITHOUT
IT.
THAT WOULD MAKE SENSE DECADES
AGO IN SANDRA DAY O'CONNOR ONCE
POINTED OUT THAT
AFFIRMATIVE-ACTION WAS A
TEMPORARY REMEDY, SOMETHING YOU
NEED UNTIL YOU DON'T NEED IT
ANYMORE LIKE CRUTCHES FOR A
SPRAINED ANKLE, TRAINING WHEELS
ON A BIKE OR THAT TOPICAL CREAM
LARRY KUDLOW RECOMMENDED.
STILL HAVE HALF A TUBE IF ANYONE
IS INTERESTED.
THE PROBLEM WITH LEFTISTS, THEY
NEVER BELIEVE ANYTHING IS
TEMPORARY UNLESS IT'S A STATUE,
THE BILL OF RIGHTS OR A FETUS.
EVERYTHING THEY ARE FOR THAT
ALWAYS STICKS AROUND, THEY GET
AMNESIA WHEN ASKED WITH WHICH
PARTY DEFENDED SLAVERY AND FOUND
THAT THE KKK.
MEANWHILE THE COURT MAJORITY
QUESTION TO THE LEGAL REASONS
FOR AFFIRMATIVE ACTION AND WHEN
HARVARD'S LAWYERS TRIED TO
DOWNPLAY USING RACE IN
ADMISSIONS, CHIEF JUSTICE
ROBERTS STATED THE OBVIOUS,
SCHOOLS WHO ASK KIDS TO CHECK A
BOX FOR THEIR RACE MUST HAVE
SOME IMPACT ON ADMISSION
DECISIONS OR ELSE IT WOULD BE
INCLUDED.
NO ONE ADDS A BOX IF THEY DON'T
WANT TO YOU TO USE THAT BOX,
TAKE IT FOR ME I SPENT FOUR
YEARS INSIDE A BOX.
UNDER NEIL CAVUTO'S BED.
ROBERTS COULD HAVE JUST SAID
LAWYERS I GOT TWO WORDS FOR YOU,
LIZ WARREN.
OR ONE WORD, POCAHONTAS.
SHE'S THE WHITE LADY WHO FAKED
BEING AN INDIAN TO GET INTO
HARVARD -- LIZ WARREN OR AS HER
TRIBAL ELDERS CALL HER, DANCES
WITH MAYONNAISE.
IF WHITE PRIVILEGE IS SUCH A
HUGE PROBLEM, WHY IS A THIRD OF
WHITE STUDENTS PRETENDING NOT TO
BE WHITE WHEN THEY APPLY TO
COLLEGE?
THEY CHECKED THE OTHER BOXES
WITH LABELS LIKE MIX, INDIGENOUS
OR RACHEL DOLEZAL.
EVEN THEY REALIZE IT'S BETTER TO
BE NONWHITE THAN WHITES, WHEN
YOU HAVE THAT KIND OF
INSTITUTIONAL RACISM YOU DON'T
NEED AFFIRMATIVE ACTION ANYMORE.
IT'S LIKE A SPRINTER FAKING
OLYMPUS IN THE CAN PARK IN
HANDICAPPED SPACES.
THE CONSERVATIVE JUSTICES DID
NOTE THEY WOULD BE WILLING TO
ALLOW STUDENTS TO DISCUSS THEIR
RACE IN THEIR APPLICATIONS BUT
IN ESSAY FORM AND THAT'S WHAT I
DID TO GET INTO BERKELEY, I TOLD
THEM HOW I WAS RAISED BY A BLACK
FAMILY.
WHICH WAS KIND OF TRUE HAVING
WATCHED EVERY SINGLE EPISODE OF
THE JEFFERSONS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
I LOVE THEM.
OF COURSE THE LEFT WASN'T
THRILLED.
SPEAK OF THE SUPREME COURT HAS
NO PROBLEM THROWING OUT
PRESIDENT AT RULING IN A REALLY
PARTISAN POLITICAL WAY.
>> THEY SAY RACE CANDY WOULD BE
CONSIDERED THERE, THE NEXT THING
WE WILL SEE SHOULD BE CONSIDERED
IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
>> THE SIX CONSERVATIVE JUSTICES
ON THE SUPREME COURT WILL LET
THEM DO IT BECAUSE THEY DON'T
ACTUALLY THINK DIVERSITY IS
IMPORTANT.
>> THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE BENEFITED
MOST FROM AFFIRMATIVE ACTION
HAVE BEEN WOMEN WHO ARE WHITE.
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION WORKS FOR ALL
THOSE OF US WHO ARE NOT ALLOWED
TO GO TO THE INSTITUTIONS WHERE
WE THOUGHT WE COULD DO OUR BEST.
>> Greg: GET USED ALL THAT
BECAUSE THE LEFT IS GOING TO RAM
THIS IDEA HOME THAT THE COURT
GETTING RID OF AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION WILL SET THE COUNTRY
BACK.
THE WAY IT'S GOING NOW HOW CAN
THAT BE A BAD IDEA?
I SAY SINCE BACK TO JANUARY OF
2017.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
RED MEAT!
THAT WAS 145 WAS SWORN IN.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS!
SHE'S THE WOMAN OF BRUCE
JENNER'S DREAMS, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR CAITLYN JENNER!
THE ONLY TIME HE SPLIT SOMEONE'S
SIDE IS WHEN HE STOLE A KIDNEY,
ACTOR, WRITER, COMEDIAN JAMIE
LISSOW.
SHE IS LIKE AN OLD CAMPAIGN AND
SIGN OFF AND FOUND FACE DOWN IN
YOUR YARD, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
KAT TIMPF.
AND HE FLIPS HIS NAILS WITH
GARDEN SHEARS MY MASSIVE
SIDEKICK AND THE N.W.A. WORLD
TELEVISION CHAMPION TYRUS.
THANK YOU FOR FLYING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY TO BE ON THIS SHOW.
>> IT IS ALWAYS MY PLEASURE I
LOOK FORWARD TO IT.
I'M A BIG FAN OF THE SHOW.
I'M A BIG FAN, I WATCH IT ALL
THE TIME.
I FEEL LIKE I'M A PERSON,
POLITICAL HUMOR IS IMPORTANT.
WHAT IS GOING ON IN THIS COUNTRY
RIGHT NOW IS SO DEPRESSING TO
SEE WHAT'S HAPPENING.
EVER SINCE A YEAR AGO, I WAS IN
THE GOVERNOR RUN AND I STARTED
TO COME FROM THE INSIDE OF
POLITICS AND START TO SEE WHAT'S
GOING ON.
IT'S A SCAM.
I GET SO UPSET WITH PEOPLE LYING
AND DOING THINGS THAT YOU NEED
TO KEEP YOUR SENSE OF HUMOR.
ABOUT ALL OF THIS STUFF.
THAT'S WHY I ENJOY THE SHOW I
ENJOY COMING IN HERE, HAVING A
GOOD LAUGH.
WE ALSO HAVE TO BE SERIOUS ABOUT
IT.
>> I'M SORRY I SENT YOU NEXT TO
JAMIE BECAUSE HE WANTED A GOOD
LAUGH.
DO YOU KNOW THERE WAS A
SUPREME COURT?
I KNOW YOU LIVE IN ALASKA, UP
THERE THEY HAVE A LOOSE AND
SEALS.
>> DIDN'T YOU SAY THE
SUPREME COURT WAS REGULAR COURT
WITH SOUR CREAM AND LETTUCE.
IT DIDN'T GET BY ME THAT YOU'RE
TELLING CAITLIN HOW AWESOME IT
IS THAT SHE CAME ALL THE WAY
FROM CALIFORNIA, CALIFORNIA WAS
ONE OF MY TWO LAYOVERS.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M FLYING EVERY WEEK IN THE
MIDDLE OF A COUNTRY NOT A
THANK YOU ONE TIME NOT EVEN A
LITTLE BIT AND I'M BIGGER THAN
CAITLIN, STILL.
>> PHYSICALLY BIGGER.
>> I'M HAVING TO LIVE HERE.
>> NEVER THANKED HER ONCE FOR
WALKING INTO WORK, NOT EVEN
ONCE.
>> THE WORST COMMUTE IS WALKING
FROM THE WEST SIDE TO THE
STUDIO.
...
ALL THAT HUMAN.
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE HARVARD TRY
TO PULL ONE OVER BY HAVING A
DISPROPORTIONATE AMOUNT OF
ASIANS AT THEIR SCHOOL, THEY'RE
GOING TO FIND OUT THEY ARE THE
BEST.
♪ ♪
I THINK THAT'S ALL I HAVE TO SAY
BECAUSE I COULDN'T POSSIBLY
COMMENT, I CAN POSSIBLY BE WHITE
HAIR.
MY DOCTOR TOLD ME WHEN I GO OUT
IN THE SUN TO WEAR SPF 100 DID
YOU KNOW THAT WAS REAL?
IT'S FOR BABIES AND ME.
I SQUEEZE THE BOTTLE A T-SHIRT
CAME OUT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I LOVED HOW HE WAS ABLE TO
WORK THAT INTO THIS AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION SEGMENT BY SAYING I DON'T
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THIS, I'M
WHITE.
>> I COME FROM THE ATHLETIC
WORLD AND THERE IS AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION THERE.
THAT DOESN'T MAKE ANY DIFFERENCE
WHAT YOUR RACES WITH THE COLOR
OF YOUR SKIN IS, THE FIRST
PERSON TO THE FINISH LINE WINS.
IT'S ABOUT WHO'S GOING TO WORK
THE HARDEST, WHO'S GOING TO HAVE
THE TALENTS TO BE ABLE TO GET
OUT THERE TO WIN.
I'M NEVER BEEN A BIG FAN OF
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION, I THINK IT'S
NOT GOOD FOR OUR UNIVERSITIES.
A LOT OF THESE STUDENTS WHO GO
THERE, THEY SEE OTHER STUDENTS
THERE AND THEY WONDER WHY ARE
THEY THERE, ARE THEY THERE
BECAUSE OF THEIR MERIT, WHAT
THEY WERE ABLE TO DO IN THEIR
LIFE AND THE GRADES THAT THEY
GET THAT THEY WORKED SO HARD
FOR?
MAYBE NOT, MAYBE THEY ARE THERE
BECAUSE OF THE COLOR OF THEIR
SKIN OR THEIR ETHNIC BACKGROUND.
I WANT THE BEST PEOPLE QUALIFIED
TO GO TO THAT SCHOOL.
NO MATTER WHAT THE COLOR OF YOUR
SKIN IS, YOUR ETHNIC BACKGROUND.
>> Greg: IT SERVED A
PURPOSE -- WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
>> I'M LISTENING INTENTLY TO YOU
BABBLING.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> LIKE I SAID THERE WAS A TIME
IN THIS COUNTRY WHEN AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION WAS NECESSARY BECAUSE WE
HAD TO EVEN THE PLAYING FIELD,
BUT WE'VE GOTTEN TO A POINT NOW
WHERE IF YOU DO THE WORK YOU GET
THE OPPORTUNITY.
AMERICA IS ABOUT OPPORTUNITY
NOW.
HERE'S THE THING AND I'VE SEEN
THIS FIRSTHAND AS A TEACHER AND
BEING OUT -- WHEN YOU CULTURALLY
IN YOUR FAMILY PUT AN EMPHASIS
ON EDUCATION LIKE A LOT OF
AMERICAN FAMILIES ESPECIALLY
AFRICAN AMERICAN FAMILIES, WHITE
FAMILIES WE PUT OUR KIDS
INTEREST ON HIGH STAKE [BLEEP]
WITH NO REWARD LIKE MY SON IS
GOING TO PLAY IN THE NFL MY
DAUGHTER IS GOING TO BE AN
ACTRESS AND A SINGER.
THOSE THINGS ARE UP TO SOMEBODY
ELSE.
WHEN YOU PUT THOSE WORK ETHICS
IN MATH, SCIENCE, EDUCATION LIKE
MOST ASIAN FAMILIES DO THAT IS
THE EMPHASIS.
BEING THE DOCTOR IS THE STAR,
NOT GETTING A SPRITE COMMERCIAL.
OF COURSE YOU WILL SEE IF THE
FAMILIES PUT THE EFFORT, THEY
ARE THE ONES WHO SHOULD BE THE
FIRST ONES PICKED TO GO TO
COLLEGE BECAUSE THEY DID THE
WORK.
THEY EMPHASIZED WHAT WAS
IMPORTANT AT WHAT LIBERALS DO
NOW WITH AFFIRMATIVE ACTION AS
THEY HAVE REVERSED THAT
COMMITTEE DON'T USE IT TO GET
GROUPS IN, THEY USE IT TO DIVIDE
AND ELIMINATE, WE WANT TO
SEGREGATE THIS AND IF YOU ARE
WHITE FROM ILLINOIS AND YOU
WORKED YOUR ASS OFF AND YOU
DIDN'T PLAY SPORTS BUT YOU HIT
THE BOOKS AND YOU HAVE THE GPA
THERE IS NO REASON YOU SHOULD GO
TO THAT SCHOOL BASED ON
OPPORTUNITY INTO MERIT OTHER
THAN SOMEBODY SITTING THERE
GOING WE CAN'T HAPPEN BECAUSE
HE'S WHITE, IT'S NO DIFFERENCE
THEN IN THE 60s SAYING WE
CAN'T HAVE HIM BECAUSE HE'S
BLACK.
SPEAK OUT IF YOU OPEN THAT
STATEMENT UP WITH AT ONE POINT
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION HAD ITS
PLACE -- I AGREE WITH THAT
STATEMENT, IT DID HAVE IT.
ALMOST LIKE TODAY, THE WORLD WE
ARE LIVING IN, WE HAVE GONE PAST
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION.
WE HAVE TO GO TO THE NEXT STEP
AND IT'S THE SAME THING YOU'RE
SEEING RIGHT NOW WITH THE WHOLE
BULK WORLD, PEOPLE ARE SICK OF
IT, IT'S RIDICULOUS.
>> Greg: I'VE GOT TO GET CAT
IN HERE, I THINK IT WOULD BE
GREAT IN THE SUPREME COURT'S
BECAUSE YOU ALREADY SPENT MOST
OF YOUR DAY IN A ROBE ARGUING.
[LAUGHTER]
>> A SIGNIFICANT PART OF IT,
YEAH.
IT DEPENDS ON WHAT DAY --
SUNDAY, YES.
>> GOOD ONE, THANK YOU.
>> ARE YOU FILMING MY APARTMENT?
>> NO COMMENTS.
JUST DON'T MOVE THAT CHAMPAGNE
BOTTLE.
>> I THINK DIVERSITY IS A GOOD
THING I THINK THERE'S OTHER
KINDS OF DIVERSITY BESIDES THE
COLOR OF YOUR SKIN AND YOUR.
I THINK THOSE ARE ACTUALLY TWO
THE LEAST RELEVANT THINGS IN
DETERMINING WHO SOMEONE IS AS A
PERSON AND APPARENTLY THAT MAKES
ME A BIGOT.
THAT MAKES NO SENSE TO ME I KNOW
SOME PEOPLE HAVE TO GO THROUGH
CERTAIN KIND OF ADVERSITY IN
THEIR LIVES BUT THERE ARE OTHER
WAYS TO FIND OUT THAT SOMEONE
HAS GONE THROUGH THAT, MAYBE AN
ESSAY, COLLEGE ADMISSIONS NEVER
ASK FOR THOS